:
>> Robert Newlen: Good
morning, everyone.
And on behalf of Dr.
Carla Hayden the librarian
of Congress, it's my pleasure
to welcome you to the library.
My name is Robert Newlen.
I have the pleasure of serving
as the deputy librarian
of Congress.
We are delighted
to be partnering
with the Kennedy Center and
Washington Performing Arts
and co-hosting this special
symposium Leading the Change:
Orchestra Innovation
and the Shift Festival.
There's been a wonderful
buzz about this excellent
and exciting festival
around Washington this week,
about the great concerts and
events like this one that reach
out into the community
of music lovers.
And we're really
pleased to be part of it.
I would first like to
acknowledge our partners,
the creators and presenters
of the Shift Festival.
First, the -- and I can only
say the fabulous Debra Rutter,
the president of the Kennedy
Center who was traveling
with the National Symphony
Orchestra this week
in its Russia trip.
Robert van Leer the Center's
vice president for programming.
And Jenny Bilfield,
president and CEO
of Washington Performing Arts.
I know that among our audience
this morning we have music
lovers, composers,
arts professionals
and representatives for several
of the very top orchestras
in the nation.
And I would like to welcome
particularly Jesse Rosen,
president and CEO of the
League of American Orchestras.
It's very appropriate
for us to host you today
because great music has a
very strong tradition here
at the library.
Many of you are probably aware
of our historic concert series,
now over 90 years old.
This wonderful auditorium
that you're sitting
in that's a bit chilly this
morning, was built in 1925
by Elizabeth Spregg Coolidge
in a groundbreaking
public/private partnership.
And it's been the home
of terrific concerts
over the years, everything
from classical, jazz, pop,
country and much more.
Our stage has seen the premier
of Aaron Copeland's
Appalachian Spring,
now an icon of the repertoire,
along with performances
by composers from Bartok to
Bernstein and Stevie Wonder.
And I invite you to spend some
time looking at the display
of manuscripts our curators
have prepared for you,
just a few of the major
orchestral works in our vaults.
Here at the library we share
your passion for creating superb
and vibrant programs that open
all our doors to the widest,
most diverse and most
engaged audiences possible.
Like you, we are committed
to innovation and to outreach
and education and increased
access for young people.
I should mention that a little
later you'll hear a stellar
youth orchestra group from
Play On Philly which travelled
down this morning just
to perform for you.
On a personal note, I've been
reading a lot about Shift
and the kinds of
outreach you do.
As somebody that had virtually
no music education as a child
or as a teenager, the kind
of work you're doing is
so important, and I wish I'd had
the opportunity to be exposed
to the kinds of things
you're doing.
Regarding our current
programs here at the library,
I can't resist by leading
you with mention of something
that you may have read about in
the New York Times yesterday.
And that is something
that's coming
to the library the
first week of May.
It's called Biblio-Disco-Tech,
and it's a library-wide
celebration of disco culture,
music, dance and fashion.
So over the week we're going to
have a number of music experts,
panels that are all
open to the public.
Tim Gunn from Project
Runway will be here
to talk about '70's fashion.
And the week will be
capped on Saturday,
May 6th with a disco party
in the great hall featuring
none other than Gloria Gaynor.
So we are so excited.
Miss Gaynor's song I
Will Survive was put
on our song registry and
got lots of publicity,
so we decided, let's
really celebrate this
and bring Miss Gaynor
to the library.
So she graciously agreed.
So watch our website.
It is a ticketed event, but
it's free so take a look
at our website, because I know
tickets will go very, very fast.
So let me state finally that
the Library of Congress music
of all kinds is a crucial and
vital element in our mandate
to preserve and present the
best in our American culture.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
If this is your first
visit to the Library,
I hope it won't be your last.
Check out our website, LOC.gov.
We have programs all
year long and music
and every other topic
you can imagine.
This is your library.
It belongs to the United
States and to the world.
So we're just delighted
to have you here.
And please enjoy your day.
Thanks again.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Bilfield: Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Jenny Bilfield with
Washington Performing Arts.
It's wonderful to
see you all today.
Excuse me just one moment.
And thank you so much, Robert,
for the wonderful
introduction of our guests.
We're so happy to be
here, very grateful
to the Library of Congress.
And I want to welcome
you on behalf
of Washington Performing Arts,
the League of American
Orchestras,
and the Kennedy Center.
I bring greetings from
Debra Rutter my friend
and collaborator
who is traveling
with the National Symphony
Orchestra this week in Russia
and she couldn't be here.
I know that she's
very disappointed
to miss participating in
a festival that she has
so strongly believed
in and been committed
to from the very,
very beginning.
So after two and a half years
of planning, we have arrived
at this week and it's very
exciting to start it here
in a place that is of music and
has had such an important impact
in the cultural life
of this country.
I wanted to give you a little
bit of a background about Shift.
And it was really founded
based upon a vantage point
of optimism.
Optimism about orchestras
and the sense
that orchestras are the hubs
of culture and learning within
and outside their institutions.
You know, very often
orchestras make the news
when there is some strife,
when there's a strike
or a negotiation or
something is going poorly.
And in contrast, Debra
and I felt very strongly
that there were wonderful
stories to be told,
and that orchestras were doing
some of the most creative,
energizing and energized
work within the arts world.
And we wanted to
tell that story.
We also believed that if
audiences could experience this,
they might actually shift their
perceptions of orchestras.
So for that reason,
Shift was the name.
A shift in mindset, a
shift in perception,
a shift in experience.
So I hope if you travel
through the whole week with us,
you will have that
experience yourself.
We were inspired by
the multi-year series
of orchestral performances
in New York under the name
of Spring for Music that were
presented at Carnegie Hall
by Tom Morris, Marylou Falconi
and David Foster, and designed
to highlight creative
programming.
We are very grateful for
their example and the impact
of their work and their lifelong
commitment to orchestras.
From the get-go,
Washington Performing Arts
and the Kennedy Center
wanted to think expansively
and to extend the
notion of a festival
to many residencies
within a festival.
And that's what this
week is about.
We wanted to focus on orchestras
of all sizes, as you'll see.
And we wanted to in some
way transpose the great work
that orchestras do
in their hometowns
and cities to our DC community.
We believed that we had the
institutional commitment,
scale and partners
to undertake this.
And we thought of
course what better place
to showcase this work than
in the nation's capital,
the seat of government,
the center of diplomacy
and policymaking?
And quite an extraordinary
arts community as well.
Orchestras that applied to our
national call for proposals rose
to the occasion and the offered
programs and residency plans
that were ambitious,
specific and completely
and utterly reflective
of what they do well
and what they value.
The ideas leapt off the
page, and coincidentally,
all seemed to express
their unique identity
through very specific
collaborations, commissions,
partnerships and a healthy dose
of contemporary American music.
American orchestras coming
to the nation's capital
with a bumper crop of American
works, we were inspired.
Today's symposium
will give us a chance
to discuss why Shift
is important not just
in this hyper-focused lens
of a one-week festival,
but more broadly in the
context of orchestras' value
within their communities.
We'll look at the risks
and rewards of innovation,
explore what's gotten us to this
point, and we'll have a chance
to actually hear music with a
Play On Philly chamber ensemble.
I'm very happy to have
music at the centerpiece
of this festival
and the symposium.
From the get-go, the Andrew W.
Mellon Foundation supported our
vision and provided
generous seed funding
that enabled us to
green-light Shift.
And I'm very pleased that
Susan Fader can be here
to see how this all unfolds.
Mellon support was matched by
Tina and Gary Mather, Michael
and Naomi Nidorf and the
Centine Charitable Foundation,
the DC Commission on
Arts and Humanities
which is an agency
supported in part
by the National Endowment
for the Arts.
And also by the Abramson
Family Foundation,
Betsy and Robert Fineburg,
Morton and Norma Lee Funger
and Daniel R. Lewis
among other donors.
We're very grateful
for their support
and we could not have done
it without them, literally.
Huge thanks to our teams,
boards, our partners
and to the participating
orchestras, the staff,
musicians and their boards.
A special shout-out
to Samantha Polluck
from Washington Performing Arts,
and Jamie Brumus, counterparts
who worked so closely and
really bore the lion's share
of organizing this.
They are treasures.
And when you see them, thank
them, give them a squeeze.
They deserve every good wish
and our great appreciation
for their efforts in
putting this together.
And to Kathy French who
believed in this idea
from the very beginning.
She was part of Spring
for Music and she is here
in Washington DC, and a
lifelong friend of the arts
and a longtime CEO of the
League of American Orchestras.
Jesse Rosen is her successor.
We're very grateful, Kathy,
for your support early on.
We're so happy that so many of
you who believed in this early
on are here with us today
to see how this is launched.
We're very grateful.
So I'll play the role of MC
today, as you may have gathered.
And very soon moderator
for the first panel.
But right now it gives
me great pleasure
to introduce Rhona Wolfe
Friedman who is commissioner
on the DC Commission
of Arts and Humanities.
She is one of our city's
most emphatic evangelists
for the arts and she's
a cherished friend.
She's an attorney
with master's degrees
in clinical psychology
and decorative arts.
She's hardly an underachiever.
She's a remarkable and
accomplished woman.
The focus of her advocacy and
commission tenure have been
in arts education policy
and also around quantifying
and growing the creative
economy in Washington DC.
She is on the board of
THEARC, which is an acronym
for the Town Hall Education
Arts and Recreation Center.
And she served on the boards
of the Washington
Ballet and Lab School.
She is fiercely committed
to this community
and to its citizens.
We've asked her to open
our symposium by speaking
about the importance
of Shift and orchestras
as an essential civic asset in
strengthening our communities.
Please join me in welcoming
Rhona Wolfe Friedman.
[ Applause ]
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Good morning.
I'd like to thank the
Library of Congress
for hosting this
wonderful symposium.
And a huge debt of gratitude
to the Kennedy Center
and Washington Performing
Arts and the League
of American Orchestras for
their collaborative efforts
in presenting Shift, the
festival of American orchestras.
How lucky we are in our nation's
capital to have a week-long,
immersive musical experience.
The concept of Shift
defines what is happening
in the arts today.
The Shift festival here
celebrates American music,
highlights different
size orchestras,
where they perform
and whom they serve.
This focus on American
orchestras allows audiences
and participants to
educate themselves
about music perhaps
not familiar to them.
At the same time, it affords
participating orchestras the
chance to showcase
new compositions
and perform their finest works.
What a winning combination
we have here,
music and distinctive
outreach programs.
We think about the
shifting landscape.
I would like you to think
about President John F.
Kennedy's quote: "Art means more
than the recitation of the past.
It means the free and
unconfined search for new ways
of expressing the
experience of the present
and the vision of the future."
In the broadest sense, the arts
including the humanities can be
thought of as the four
C's: curiosity, creation,
connection and communication.
In 1943, Abraham Maslow proposed
a theory of human motivation,
now called the hierarchy
of human needs.
It encompassed eventually
innate curiosity.
He formed a pyramid with
base needs at the bottom.
Safety, moving up the
ladder to love, belonging,
esteem and finally
self-actualization.
I submit that the arts play
a vital role in meeting
so many of our human needs.
They help provide an
understanding of our emotions,
increase our self-awareness
and bridge the gap
between different cultures.
How would a society be able to
preserve and share its culture,
progress and valued
traditions if not for the arts?
People connect, thrive and
prosper through the arts.
In our complex world today,
the arts are a necessary tool
to help manage the shifting
dynamic issues we face.
We cannot replace the arts, nor
allow them to be diminished.
They are a lens from
which to look at the past
and look forward to the future.
Without the arts, we become
a silent society unable
to accurately evaluate
our surroundings.
Orchestras as an indispensable
art form play an important part
in American life.
They are part and parcel of
our life today in both large
and small communities.
They improve the quality of the
cultural fabric of a community
and foster pride in
local neighborhoods.
In 2016, Ian David
Moss discussed the arts
in the Stanford Social
Innovation Review.
He suggested using a holistic
approach, tying the arts
into wellbeing and
quality of life.
We can use this same approach
to expand the definition
of what an orchestra
is: promoting wellbeing
and enhancing the
quality of life.
Orchestras are a critical
resource for arts education.
Playing different instruments,
they demonstrate teamwork
at its highest level.
Older models of music
education are shifting today.
Schools with orchestra-based
programs are demonstrating
that their populations
have greater skills
than students lacking
a musical education.
While students develop
musical talents,
they're also increasing
competencies in subjects
such as math and reading.
To be pragmatic,
the arts make money.
They are a critical
economic driver
and force in this country.
Orchestras play a key role
in an economy of a city.
They help populations develop
skills that are transferrable
and assist in the
revitalization of neighborhoods.
Both large and small orchestras
understand that they need
to be relevant to
their communities.
Today, they're engaging in
novel ways to include residents
with varying economic, racial
and social backgrounds.
A necessary shift is
transforming the way orchestras
strengthen, broaden and
deepen their relationships.
The shift is multidimensional.
Orchestras are connecting
and serving the community not
by exclusivity but
by inclusivity.
Orchestras should keep
advancing a very basic concept:
that a healthy community
must have an orchestra,
and demonstrate that this
orchestra is a powerful tool
to form connections and
promote vibrancy throughout
the community.
Some approaches an
orchestra may consider
to remain relevant are
one, act with a purpose;
one that's directed outside
of the orchestra itself.
Pursue goals that
serve community needs.
Evaluate; evaluate what
works and what's dead weight.
Move ahead with strategies that
are working and stay focused.
Play towards strength.
Reality can bite.
Lessen the sting with realistic
goals that allow for shifts.
Leverage the power of
orchestra leaders and musicians
to forge dynamic community
interactions through education,
networking and engagement.
And last, reboot.
Reboot to help work
for a paradigm shift
in the way a community
views orchestra.
Encourage experimentation
in thought and action,
which brings me back
to the Shift Festival.
Focusing on orchestras
in our nation's capital
is a powerful reminder
of their importance.
This does not detract
from non-orchestral
musical expression.
This creative festival moves
forward with goals, purpose
and community involvement.
It demonstrates how music
can lift the human spirit,
how orchestras are
involved in our community
and for a $25 ticket, how people
can connect with an art form
that has withstood
the test of time.
And finally, I would
be remiss as the member
of an arts commission
that receives money
from the National
Endowment for the Arts
if I did not offer a reminder
of how critical the NEA is
for sustaining the arts.
Not just here, but in every
community in this country.
The NEA sends grants to
every congressional district
in the nation.
It's imperative to
fight for its survival.
Thank you and please
enjoy the Shift Festival.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Thank you, Rhona.
That was such a perfect
introduction
to the topic of this panel.
And I would love, having had
a chance to introduce Rhona,
to also introduce
the other panelists.
To Rhona's left we have Thomas
Wilkins, the music director
of the Omaha Symphony,
principle conductor
of the Hollywood Bowl Orchestra,
who also holds a chair
with the Boston Symphony for
family and youth concerts.
He is so active nationally,
a very inventive programmer,
and I've had the pleasure
of watching his work
over many years,
and my kudos to you.
I know that you're
equally committed
to community development
and arts education,
but well beyond the
arts as well.
I was interested to see
that you're on the boards
of the Greater Omaha
Chamber of Commerce,
the Charles Drew
Health Center in Omaha,
the Center Against Spouse Abuse
in Tampa Bay, and the Museum
of Fine Arts in St. Petersburg,
which is very expansive.
And I hope you'll speak
about how all these different
commitments and interests
and passions intersect
in your musical work.
I'm also delighted that you have
studied at Shenandoah University
which is a source of wonderful
training and many musicians,
and also the New
England Conservatory.
So you grew up not terribly
far from Washington.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Right.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Thank
you so much for being here.
And then to my right, Stanford
Thompson who's a trumpeter
and executive director and
founder of Play On Philly
which you'll have a
chance to hear a little bit
in about 45 minutes or an hour.
In 2010 he founded the El
Sistema-inspired program
in Philadelphia where
he currently serves
as executive director.
And he secured over
$9 million in funding
which has definitely
impacted the lives of hundreds
of children in Philadelphia.
He believes orchestras offer
us lessons in leadership,
innovation, diversity
and inclusion.
And his work absolutely
speaks to that.
His vision is very
sharp and focused.
He's trained as a
professional trumped,
active across many ensembles.
He performs and teaches,
collaborates,
conducts master classes.
He's a native of
Atlanta, Georgia.
So one of your orchestras
is coming to visit.
I love that this
all ties together.
Yes. And he holds degrees from
the Curtis Institute of Music,
New England Conservatory's
fellows program.
He serves on the boards of
the Curtis Institute of Music,
Interlochen Center for the
Arts, the Philadelphia chapter
of the American Composers
Forum, and the El Sistema USA
and the Philadelphia
Wind Symphony.
So thank you all for being here.
Many different experiences and
approaches to our discussion.
I will sit down.
I wanted to do a more
formal introduction.
But thank you.
And I was wondering if you
could speak a little bit
to what this shift if
from your vantage point.
What's happened in the past ten
years that is noteworthy to you
and important to reflect upon at
this moment in this gathering?
>> Stanford Thompson:
Good morning.
[Laughs] I think for me it
goes back a little bit longer
than just the past ten years.
I think it's really important to
understand that the orchestras
that we enjoy today were built
around a social mission back --
gosh, starting in the
1880's, especially going
into the beginning
of the next century.
These were immigrants that
were coming to America.
They were setting
up new communities.
If it was Minneapolis or Chicago
or Boston or Philly or Baltimore
or New York or Cincinnati or
Cleveland, what was important
to keep those communities
together was their culture
and their identity.
And a lot of that revolved
around classical
music and orchestras.
The musicians played an
important role in making sure
that community music
schools were set up,
that orchestras were established
and that they were actually
working hand-in-hand.
Philadelphia's a
perfect example.
1900, the orchestras form.
1904, the Settlement
Music School.
They were teaching kids in the
community for a nickel or less.
And then they found out
20 years after that,
some of the kids
were pretty good.
So they created the
Curtis Institute of Music.
And for the first four years,
tuition was $500 a
year, a lot of money.
And they thought that was pretty
crazy because of course a lot
of the families could
not afford to pay it.
So the woman who
founded the school,
who also founded the Settlement
Music School and also helped
to found the Philly Orchestra,
put down $12 million in 1928
to make sure that there
was a tuition-free policy.
And there is this connection
between the musicians
that played and taught and
mentored, and it was all
around trying to in many ways
keep body and soul together.
So all of that stuff
just blossomed.
In the '60's it was wonderful
because then you had Wallace
Foundation and Ford Foundation,
a couple of others
that said, "You know,
I think that these musicians and
the music that they're providing
to the community should
be made more available."
So they turned orchestras
into full-time gigs, 52 weeks.
And there was a shift.
And the money shifted
towards those musicians.
Endowments were created.
Orchestras were more healthy.
But the public, they
were picking up the cost
and making sure that
kids had access
to music in all the schools.
And that worked,
until the early '80's.
And of course that
infrastructure
in the public schools
started to fall apart
to what we are now experiencing.
And it's at a point where
there's not enough public money,
but sure these [inaudible]
have a bunch.
And that's where the money is.
And I work with organizations
where we're trying
to I think collectively among
several of the boards that I'm
on -- we're trying to raise
half a billion dollars
for endowments.
Now not to say that the
orchestras don't deserve them,
and they do, but when we
watch the infrastructure
for music falling
apart, knowing that used
to be a really strong
connection,
and it was important, then
of course what will
the shift be now?
So you know, I just think
that half a billion dollars
in Philadelphia for
example, that organizations
between the orchestra and Curtis
-- half a billion that they need
for their endowments -- I think
half a billion invested in youth
in the city would
definitely go a long way
with of course making
classical music
and orchestras much
more relevant.
I think it would also open
up, and as we have found
in even the money that we
have raised, a vast majority
of that money comes
from education
and social service
private funders that want
to see something different.
There's more money there.
So when I look at the
Shift, I hope that the shift
that we make is that we
can no longer divorce those
who play music and those
who teach the music.
Because I think both of those
actually working together is
exactly the infrastructure and
foundation that we really need
to build and grow professional
orchestras in the country.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Thank you.
And I want to come back
to some of the themes
and give Tom a chance
to weight in too.
>> Thomas Wilkins: There
was a time in my life
when I was really irritated
by the word relevance.
Because I believed
-- and to your point,
it really goes back further
than the last ten years.
We came with the word
relevant in our industry
because we were losing traction.
And we were indeed losing
traction of funders as well,
but we were losing
interest in the population.
And so we had to come up with
a way to justify our existence,
and so we started using
this word relevant.
But I'm not convinced
that across the board we
were committed to relevance.
I thought maybe a different
word would have been engagement
or deeper connection.
I've wanted to be a conductor
since I was eight years old.
And I first heard an orchestra
when I was eight years old.
And I was born to a
single mother on welfare,
living in a housing project.
And when I talk to funders
and leaders in communities
about this, I say that music
literally saved my life.
And so I come at music from
a different perspective.
If I believe that it is
life-affirming and life altering
in my case as it surely
is, why would I want
to leave anyone behind
in a community?
I'm not worried about Mozart's
ability to take care of himself,
or Beethoven's ability
to take care of himself.
There's a reason why we still
listen to that music today.
What I was worried about was
how we get that music to people
so that it can be life-altering
and life-affirming.
And so I have always
believed that relevance had
to be earnest, and that meant
that we had to find ourselves
in places other than
a concert hall.
And we had to be okay with that.
And we had to be
comfortable with that.
Because if you can't get past
need, you'll never believe
that this music is as
transformative as it is.
And so I would like to think
that this idea of Shift means
that orchestras all across
this nation are really figuring
out that if this music is
as life-changing as it is,
it is incumbent upon us to
get it to as many entities
and people groups as possible.
I often say that I try to
take my music more seriously
than I take myself.
So I don't mind if I'm
sitting in a community center
at the Omaha Housing Authority
with kazoos and a room full
of people who don't
have any options.
But now all of a sudden, here
is one that they do have.
And it's the only one
that we have to offer,
but it's the best one.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Rhona,
is there something
you'd like to add?
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Well, I know that as part
of the commission,
that's our goal,
is to reach out into
the communities,
especially in DC
east of the river
which is the underserved
communities in DC.
And as a board member,
that's what we do.
We bring music, art,
theater across the river.
And I agree with
you wholeheartedly.
I think if you don't reach out
into the community and connect,
and connect, not just reach out,
that music endeavors will fail.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Yeah.
I think that part of it was --
I gave a speech to MOLA which
is the Major Orchestra Libraries
Association, because
my librarian
in Omaha hosted it one year.
And it was called No
Excuses Necessary.
And what I did just for fun
was I played three recordings.
One was Tchaikovsky and
another was something by Grieg.
And when I played
those excerpts,
you could see all the
librarians in the room
and they were going, "Oh yeah."
And then I played the last
of Bernstein's Three
Dances from on the Town.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-de-ba-da-ba-do-da.
And you could see them
all kind of looking
at each other and smiling.
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Guilty pleasure.
>> Thomas Wilkins: And
my point was, you know,
the Tchaikovsky is
actually a drinking song.
"I found a coin,
I want a drink."
Forgive me, I don't know
what the exact title is.
I Have a Coin, I Want a Drink.
Those composers like
Tchaikovsky and Beethoven --
not so much Beethoven,
but Mozart for sure,
Marlor for sure --
they understood that if
their music was going
to have a mass appeal
to the general public,
it had to relate to them.
And that's why we have
Klesber and Marlor
and that's why we
have folk music
and the whole nationalistic
sort of school of composition.
But we in America almost feel
as if we have to apologize
when Americanism finds
itself in our music.
We come up with words like,
"It's a synthesis of jazz."
You know, so that it
sounds intellectual.
And I'm thinking, "Why should
we apologize for that?"
Why? Because we have always
believed that we operate
in basically a western
European tradition.
And we believe that if
we don't live our lives,
speak our language and carry
our attitudes in that tradition,
that people aren't going
to take us seriously.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
And you've hit on so many
interesting things here.
The first I want to
touch upon is this shift
from the let's call it
relevance from the purview
of one department, the
education community outreach
is responsible.
And then the rest of
the orchestra does this
to actually shifting the
institutional DNA to be one
that is much more porous and
has that sense of excitement
from the top, from the
directors, the founders,
leaders, to feel and to be
very present with the community
and in the community and
to have the community feel
as if it's monolithic.
But to have members
of the community feel very
part of the orchestra.
And it's not simply to secure
that grant or to check a box.
It's actually to
fundamentally rearrange the DNA
of an orchestra to be a
community, a living, breathing,
evolving community institution.
So that's a very
big shift as well.
Ironically, in speaking
with European orchestras
which are the ones
that theoretically
American orchestras have
in the past tried to emulate,
some of the most adventuresome,
well-resourced education
programs
and community-based
programs, are on display
with European orchestras.
So as American orchestras,
our building that sense
of porousness -- so many
European orchestras have been
in the vanguard of that through
very imaginative collaborations.
I would love it if both of
you would speak about some
of the things that have
excited you most musically
when you have really been at
sort of the most open, engaging,
porous, as music directors, as
creative innovators yourselves.
What are examples of moments
when that's come together
and just been so satisfying?
>> Stanford Thompson: Oh wow,
we shared one in Detroit.
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Okay, tell us.
Perfect.
>> Stanford Thompson:
This last month?
>> Thomas Wilkins: I think so.
>> Stanford Thompson: Right.
Wow, yeah, last month.
This was at the SINCS
Conference and Competition.
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Explain what SINCS is.
>> Stanford Thompson: It's a
20-year-old organization founded
by Aaron Dorkin who is now
the dean of the music school,
art school at University
of Michigan.
But they've been focused over
the past 20 years in really kind
of pushing the diversity
and inclusion conversation
in the field of classical music.
So a lot of success that they
have seen over that amount
of time, but they host
every year a competition
for string players, both
pretty much high school
and college age students.
And they also run side by side a
conference called SINCS Connect.
And at the competition, after
the competitors were there,
we performed a piece by
Gerald Thomson, The Last Words
of the Unarmed, which literally
took the last words of people
like Trayvon Martin,
Eric Garner.
But there were I believe seven
people that were highlighted.
But it literally took the last
two or three words and put it
into a really, really
powerful 15-minute piece.
And I will say it was the most
powerful experience I've ever
had on a stage.
We all have been around
the conversations.
We've seen everything
on the news.
We've heard all the
arguments from all sides.
But to have that
artistic display --
I'll never forget
the first rehearsal.
I was playing the
trumpet in the orchestra.
But sitting there,
I mean it was tough.
I mean, that first
rehearsal for everybody
in the orchestra was really
difficult to get through.
And I believe the
connection that we made
at that performance was
something I've never felt,
I've never seen.
And I just think when something
is -- to not use relevant,
but something that is that
engaging, that puts a spotlight
on a really big problem that
we're having and that we've done
that through the
medium of an orchestra,
I believe that we made a
really powerful connection
that I think a lot of people
that were in that hall
that day will be
able to build upon.
>> Thomas Wilkins: There
are several that I think of,
but we have in Omaha what
we call community partners,
and they range anywhere
from Nebraska Medical Center
to Girls, Inc., the
Omaha Housing Authority.
So there are a lot
of things that we do
that are less attached to a
performance and more attached
to either delivering music or
delivering access to music.
But for me, I still
have to go back
to this Omaha Housing Authority
example where we send musicians
out -- there's a retirement
center that exists there,
and these are indeed people
who have no options left.
And most are elderly,
but some are not.
This is just where they land.
And so we send musicians
out on a regular basis
and our education person asked
if I would be willing to go out.
I said, "Yeah, but
let's do something fun."
And we literally
brought in kazoos.
I'm not kidding.
And my job was to conduct
this now kazoo orchestra.
And I must say that we
spent more time laughing
because there was nothing more
ridiculous than that scene.
But what really sort of blessed
my heart was when they got
to come to my concert.
Now in Omaha we have now
-- it's ten years old,
but at the time it was newer
-- $100 million concert hall.
And these people didn't
even know where it was,
let alone walk in the building.
And so not only were
they at the concert,
but then we closed
the hall afterwards
and we spent time together
in the room in the hall.
And what was so poetic was that
here was this group of people
with no predisposition
to this music.
All of a sudden,
this room was theirs
and this orchestra was theirs,
and this conductor was theirs.
And in fact, one
of the ladies said,
"I feel as if this is all ours."
I mean, she literally said that.
And you know, are they going
to buy a ticket down the road?
No, they're not.
But we have done our job
in making sure that
they understand.
I mean, one of the great gifts
of music is that it tells us
that we were built for something
greater than the despair
that we probably experience
on a regular basis.
And this was one
of those moments
when they could say,
"You know what?
I was made for something
better than this."
So for me that was my
best memory to date.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yeah, I
mean two very profound moments
around music and shared space.
And through the eloquence
of kazoo.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Or some
maybe even more profound, right.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Or
a commissioned work,
but in a very different
context, different repertoire,
but with a sense of
vision and leadership
that helped define that.
And how well equipped are
orchestras to initiate
that conversation or
comfortable, confident reaching
out to partners who are perhaps
better equipped than they are?
Because not every institution
has a smooth transition
to new leadership,
to partnerships.
Especially if an orchestra
is a dominant institution
in a community, sometimes
the messiness
of partnership can
be unfamiliar.
So how do orchestras
embrace that?
And you've created an orchestra
and we would love these sort
of different perspectives
as you're starting up
and asserting a vision and
a presence and a mission.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Sure.
Yeah, I think there's
a lot of fear.
I mean, I remember when we
started, people were like,
"Are kids going to sign up?
Are they going to show up?
Are they going to drop
out in big numbers?
Why would they want to in our
program spend three hours every
day after school learning music,
especially classical music?"
And the same thing goes for our
I think partnerships all around.
For example, what the
Philly orchestra does is
that they present
groups from the community
in the lobby before
performances.
And there was some interest
from Simon Rattle to work
with our kids five years ago,
four and five years ago
when he was in town.
And instead of having him
come up to the school,
he agreed to put the
kids on the stage right
at the beginning of the concert.
The orchestra wasn't
going to play an overture,
but the kids were going to play.
And it was a really scary thing
to go back and forth between,
"Should they be in the lobby or
should they be on the stage?"
The patrons did not pay to
hear students from west Philly
that had only been
playing a year and a half.
What would the union do?
And of course the musicians
have to warm up on the stage
for a certain period of time.
And then what happens
if there's overtime?
And there were all
these questions.
But I mean, it was
wrapped in a lot of fear.
Like how would the
kids handle that?
How would the audience
handle that?
Would it be uncomfortable?
Not to say the kids were
playing perfectly in tune.
>> Jenny Bilfield: All the
negatives of fear, yeah.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Right.
And what ended up happening is
that actually it was a
very magical experience.
We even talked about
concert tickets.
The orchestra makes
a lot of money
when Simon Rattle's in town.
But parents bought tickets at
$90, $130 to be in the room.
When that sold out, we
opened up an overflow room.
We set up a TV so that more
families could come in,
and that room was packed.
And in many ways there
was this connection
between the parents see
how hard their kids work.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yeah.
>> Thomas Wilkins: And of
course being able to now connect
that to a professional
orchestra and put that work
into perspective of what's
going on that's powerful.
The other part of it, to be
completely honest and candid,
there are not many opportunities
where a room full of people
who typically look like the
typical white audience in a city
like Philadelphia are ever on
their feet clapping for a group
of kids in west Philly.
Honestly.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yep.
>> Thomas Wilkins: And
to see that connection
between kids standing up,
accepting that applause
at the end, saying, "They're
all clapping for me,"
and watching the parents
feel, "They're all clapping
for my kid," you know, I mean
that was a really powerful bond
that was connected and I think
has allowed our relationship
and partnership with
the orchestra
and many others to flourish.
So a lot of it is we also both
organizations received big
donations after that.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins:
In the seven figures.
And it just was a
good thing to do.
It was a great experience.
>> Jenny Bilfield: We've
done some of that here too
at Washington Performing Arts.
We don't have the ensemble of
an orchestra on a regular basis,
but when there's an opportunity
to showcase either our
gospel choirs or some
of the young performers in our
education programs, we do it
and we do think about that.
Because we'll get
the nasty-gram --
I will usually get the
nasty-gram from someone who paid
for one thing, they got another.
And my response is
always, "You know what,
I'm so glad that you
came to the performance
and had the opportunity to
hear some of the young artists
who are working towards
perhaps being in the audience
or onstage in the future.
It's part of our mission."
If there has been a residency
activity in the community,
I speak about it from the
stage every single time
because I think people
understand the finished product
because they come and
the lights and the stands
and everything is set.
They don't necessarily
understand the granularity
of the process.
They don't understand or they're
not even aware of the role
of the teachers in the classroom
playing side-by-side, the buses,
the parents driving,
the catering,
the kids taking time off
from studying, you know,
coming out early in the
morning, staying late at night.
There's a process and
in some ways I worry
that we have orchestrated such
a polished finished product
that we've done it at
our own disservice.
Because it's hard
to make the urgency
of supporting the finished
product really articulate
without showing the
process where the real time
and cost and investment are.
And so I think with the question
of how all of this is going
to happen, we simply have
to say it is going to happen
and it's going to be awesome.
And you're going to be really
sad that you missed it.
And it's that sort
of confidence.
There will be cranky people,
people and organizations
that are insecure about it.
But it's the leaders of the
organizations who have to take
that deep breath and do it.
>> Thomas Wilkins: We
at the Hollywood Bowl,
we on a regular basis are
joined by YOLA, Youth Orchestra
of Los Angeles, on stage.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins: I have had
them several times playing
by themselves and also
playing with the orchestra.
And we spoke in our
sort of pre-meeting,
we talked about this a little
bit, about how important it is
for us to give words to people
who are not in our business,
because they don't
know our language.
They're not supposed
to know our language.
We shouldn't expect them to
and we shouldn't feel
bad that they don't.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins: It is our
job to teach them our words.
And I will often say to the
audience, to the audience,
when they applaud for those
kids, how grateful I am
that they took the time
to say to these kids,
"We are surrounding you.
We believe in you and we want
nothing but the best for you."
And at that moment the audience
has nothing better to do
than to take that
responsibility.
And they sit up a little
taller in their seats and go,
"Oh yeah, that's right.
That's what we're doing."
Therefore it is now
important to them
and now they understand
why YOLA is there.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
And consistently.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Right.
>> Jenny Bilfield: It's
not just a one-off.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Right.
>> Jenny Bilfield: It
becomes a regular diet
so that it's integral
to the organization.
Rhona, I would love if you
would speak about the role
of the commission in supporting
so many important arts programs
that reach schools and kids
and professional musicians.
It's a very wide
range of support
that the commission
provides to do much
of this sort of activity.
>> RWJ: We do.
We started with a very small
budget in a couple of millions.
And we went up to $18
million and we're hoping
to go up to $25 million.
Do you hear that?
[ Laughter ]
And we support a whole range
of different programming
through our granting program.
We're a granting organization.
And what we do is we have
different categories of grants.
We have startup organizations.
We have large, we have a
heritage grant for those
that have been in existence.
And people apply and through
a panel grants are awarded
throughout the city.
And we have a separate program
as I mentioned before for east
of the river to help empower
underserved communities.
And you were mentioning
before about how you reach
out into the community.
And I want to take your point
of those of us, me included,
who were not raised in a musical
background, you do have to reach
out to the audience
and make them feel
that they're important despite
the fact that they know nothing
about the musical
instrument, the composition,
the notes on the page.
And with that I think comes
-- and I call it connection.
I don't call it relevancy.
I think it becomes a partnership
and I think it's important
for audiences to
partner with orchestras
and with musical events too.
And that's what WPA
does so well.
They go out into the
community and they reach
to all different
types of populations,
and they bring them
into their fold.
Welcome them into their fold,
and that to me is why
WPA is so successful.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Thank you.
I mean one of the things --
and this was the
mantra of our founder.
And I was very pleased
to hear that the Library
of Congress actually has some
of Patrick Hayes' archives
on display outside.
I'm looking forward
to seeing them myself.
But Mr. Hayes is remembered
for intoning the phrase
of "Everybody in, nobody out."
And so when we began to
design this festival,
we wanted the musicians
to be very visible
and accessible to the audience.
We wanted the price of
course to be accessible.
We wanted to present
an experience
that would be really different
in the Kennedy center concert
hall and on our series.
And all of that agency
went to the orchestras.
But interestingly, as you'll
see throughout the week,
you're going to find
musicians at the title basin,
at the Hamilton, coaching at
schools, in galleries of art.
The sense of finished product,
of accessibility is going
to be teased out in
very different ways.
And every orchestra
and the musicians
who are making those commitments
to doing the residency
events were really excited
about doing it because
it's a way for them to get
to know our public,
to get to know you,
and to be very much themselves.
This is something that the
orchestras do organically
and well.
>> RWJ: And to build on
that is, in this city,
performing in different
venues is critical.
As opposed to maybe smaller
cities or different cities.
>> Jenny Bilfield: And different
neighborhoods and communities.
>> RWJ: Theaters, clubs, concert
halls, not just in a large,
expensive, ticket-based event.
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Yeah, and to your point,
there are many audiences who
come to an outdoor stroll-to
who might not wander
inside to a performance.
>> RWJ: That's right.
>> Jenny Bilfield: But
they've had an experience
that they might like to.
And we certainly see that
with our summer camps.
Kids have a first-time
experience with people who come
to some of our outdoor
performances.
We never know who's
in the audience
and when there's a chance
to get them excited.
And that's something we think
about a lot as a presenter.
That experience has to compete
with what people experience
on TV, the radio, what
they can dial up at home.
So it's about the musicians,
the creativity, the connection
that drives people to
experience this together.
So when you said sharing the
space, I think that's something
that even more than relevant is
perhaps the most profound thing.
It's the sharing of space
whether it's indoors
or outdoors.
>> Stanford Thompson: Right.
I also want to add to that,
I think there are needs
of the community that also
need to be listened to.
And I think some of
that is people's voices.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
>> Stanford Thompson:
When I think about --
I just don't understand
this blue team
versus red team,
urban versus rural.
I mean, schools are
bad in both places.
Kids don't have what
they need in both places.
There are not enough jobs
or opportunities to grow.
We're all in the same
boat and we're paddling
in different directions.
And it's really easy
to say, "Well,
I think we need another
youth orchestra.
We need another music camp.
We need to curate
another performance."
And quite frankly what I'm
hearing from my parents
and from the kids is that
you, kids need an opportunity.
I mean, their kids need
opportunities to grow,
to be challenged, to
be in an environment
where the bar is set
really high for them.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
>> Stanford Thompson:
Kids want activities.
They want to connect
with one another.
They want to feel
proud about something
that they have really
accomplished as a team.
And I think that they want to
be seen in a positive light.
They want their voices
to be heard.
That was powerful about
that performance in Detroit.
We're saying we are
important in many ways.
We gave voice to that.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
>> Stanford Thompson: And we
did that through the orchestra.
Then you have everybody
that sure --
I mean, we need more taxpayers.
And we need safer
streets and we need people
that are more responsible
and that are contributing
back to society.
And we can give that back.
But I just feel that when I
look at my Facebook news feed,
the big problem is what a
lot of artists are having.
And I just think that that's
not necessarily the solution.
It's really to say, what do
the people around us need?
And if we take care
of that first,
I know that we will be okay.
It's just, do we have
the will to do it?
Do we even have the
will to listen?
>> Jenny Bilfield: Right.
>> Stanford Thompson: If not,
we will continue to create stuff
that folks just don't need.
And they're not even there in
the audience to even hear it.
And then we rely on
a very small group
of people to keep this afloat.
And I just don't think that
that's going to really get us
into the next 20 years
thinking that we're going
to be even more healthy.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yeah.
>> Thomas Wilkins: May I say,
just because I want to make sure
that it gets said, almost
to both of your points.
But you said something that made
me think of it, and that is --
it was actually your
notion about being willing
to play in different places.
What I say to my orchestra
is that we're not going
to run away from
our versatility.
We're going to run
towards that versatility.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yes, yes.
>> Thomas Wilkins: Because you
mentioned in our phone meeting
that the orchestra
is like a community.
It's a diverse group
of individuals working
together for a common good.
But at least in the
orchestra world,
we can become one
thing one night --
two weeks ago, we did Ben
Folds the first night,
Pete Martini the second night
and Chasiko the third night.
Now those weren't all the same
people groups, but we were able
to be this for this
people, this for this people
and this for these people.
And we sacrificed
nothing in the process.
And sometimes that finds
itself away from the stage,
but in any case, it really is
more about us being willing
to be different things
at different times.
>> Jenny Bilfield: So ultimately
we want our organizations
to thrive.
And you know, every generation
would say they're at sort
of an existential crossroads of
doubling down and understanding
and articulating what
they can do uniquely.
There's a very different
level of engagement
and frankly I think it's one
of the most exciting parts
certainly of our work here,
is that there are so
many fantastic musicians
and creative people living
and working in Washington DC.
As a former music publisher,
I knew from the numbers
that it had one of the highest
musical populations per capita
of any place in the country.
So many choirs here.
So many people making music.
And as I moved here and heard
and saw what people were
creating in clubs, the bands,
the ensembles, the culturally
specific community performances,
I was blown away
and I thought, "Wow,
that could really inform
what we choose to program
and what we do together."
So we created a whole program
called the Mars Urban Art
Initiative where local artists
and visiting artists connect
and make music together, are
featured on our main stage,
are featured in free
performances, paid performances.
It's something that
it's not contrived.
It's a way for us
to be more fully --
a fuller, more dynamic
organization.
Because we have local
artists who are fantastic
and who we can discover
and grow through.
I mean the whole Go Go movement
here, we had David Harrington
with the string quartet
visiting a couple weeks ago.
And he's traveled
all over the world.
I think many of us have
discovered new music
through his sort of cultural
anthropological lens.
And one of the little
girls in the class
that the quartet played
for raised her hand
after they had played music
from Armenia and Azerbaijan,
and she said, "Do you
play any Go Go music?"
And he said, "Well,
what's Go Go music?"
And she described it.
And then he came into my
office afterwards, he said,
"I have to hear about
this Go Go music."
And so we played
some Chuck Brown
and some covers and
he said, "Okay.
I'm always learning.
And of course it would be a
10-year-old in the class."
And he had that sense of
curiosity and sense of curiosity
about place and the
specificity of communities,
and learned something
at that moment.
And that little girl who had
the courage to raise her hand
and push him perhaps pushed
him in a creative direction
that will inform
a future program
that we will bring
to our stages.
And we presented the Go
Go symphony in the past,
but this could be an
interesting new collaboration.
So I think that's a
wonderful sense of discovery,
if you feel it authentically.
We're always learning.
Communities change,
evolve in different ways.
And I love that you're finding
resonant ways to support
that in your own
programming and work.
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
I wanted to say something
about arts and arts education,
which is very near
and dear to my heart.
You mentioned about bringing
opportunities to youth.
When the ARC was built as a
$28 million beautiful glass
structure in southeast, and it
houses Living School of Music,
Washington Ballet -- it was
the Corkrane, now it's going
to be the Philips Boys and Girls
Clubs, and just a whole host.
And I was on the board of a
dance company at that time
and we were really worried, if
we build it, will they come?
And we built it.
And they opened it and we said,
"Oh God, if we have ten kids
to start in music and if we
have five kids in dance,"
especially we wanted some
boys, not just all girls.
We opened the doors and had
like 200 people the first day,
400 within the first week.
And it's of course
pay what you can.
But it was bringing
the opportunity
and giving people a
chance to do something
and introducing an art
form to them, music, dance.
And it really changed the
landscape of the community.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Yeah.
So I know that we have a
performance to look forward to.
Are there sort of some final
words you'd like to share?
Or should we jump into your
introduction of Play On Philly?
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Jump into music.
>> Jenny Bilfield: Well, thank
you for a wonderful discussion.
[ Applause ]
>> Stanford Thompson:
So we are really excited
to perform a brief
piece for you.
First of all, I am
really, really proud of all
of our students at
Play On Philly.
We brought about 50
or so down yesterday.
They performed at the
ARC and also made a stop
at Howard University, and
then I believe were running
around the monuments
late at night, till 11:00
or midnight or something.
I can't remember what it was.
But I'm really, really
proud of our students.
They represent -- you'll see
about 20 or so on this stage.
There's about 50 that came.
There's several of our
students here on the front row
and several in the back.
So if you all could
give all of our kids
that are here today a
big round of applause.
[ Applause ]
And also very, very thankful
for our teaching artists
that are here, and our staff.
Especially Ryan Crump who
runs our high school program
and Chris Santentasio
who will be the conductor
of this ensemble.
So they will perform Therondel
from Bizet's L'Arlesienne.
I grew up in Atlanta.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I'm not built
for all that stuff.
But they'll perform
that for you.
I'm pretty sure that we'll
need about two minutes
to kind of get the stage set.
And if I am correct,
after their performance,
I believe we'll take
a short break.
Or do we?
>> Jenny Bilfield: We
have one more speaker,
then we'll take a break.
Yes.
>> Stanford Thompson: Okay.
So just sit tight
for a little bit.
But thank you for having our
students here to perform.
So enjoy that.
>> Chris Santentasio:
Good afternoon.
My name is Chris Santentasio.
I'm the conductor of the Play
On Philly Symphony Orchestra.
Thank you for having us today.
And we'll just begin.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Bilfield: Thank you.
Oh, please continue to join us
for just a short amount more
and then we'll take a
break in a few minutes.
But one of our many
special guests today,
it gives me great pleasure to
introduce Barbara Comstock,
Congresswoman from Virginia.
Although she recently joined
the Kennedy Center board
of trustees, Congresswoman
Comstock has been a consistent
and effective advocate
for the arts,
having spearhead the
formation of the Arts Caucus
in the Virginia House
of Delegates
where she served in that body.
The congresswoman was
elected this past November
to her second term in the House,
representing the
nearby Virginia district
in the House of Representatives.
She has been a supporter
for the arts and many
of our local cultural
organizations.
We welcome her leadership.
In the House of Representatives,
the congresswoman serves
on the Transportation and
Infrastructure Committee,
as well as the Science, Space
and Technology Committee
where she is chair of the
subcommittee on research
and technology, the House
Administration Committee
in the US House of
Representatives
and the Bicameral Joint
Economic Committee.
I now join each of you in
expressing our appreciation
for the strong voice she has
had in Congress on behalf
of northern Virginia and
metropolitan Washington.
We are honored that she is able
to be with us this morning.
Please join me in welcoming
Congresswoman Barbara Comstock.
[ Applause ]
>> BC: Thank you and
good morning to you all.
It's a pleasure to be here and
to hear that wonderful group.
How delightful to see them.
And as I was seeing them walk
out, thinking with this kind
of mentorship, with this kind of
support, they'll be able to --
whatever community they go,
hopefully they will
find a music home
for themselves in
their communities.
And that's what we're
here celebrating today.
So I'm honored to be on
the Kennedy Center Board,
also a member of the Arts
Caucus as was mentioned.
And also was able to start
an arts caucus in Virginia.
You know, we know our founding
fathers were patrons of the arts
and understood what an important
part of our education it is.
Now it's estimated that there
are over 100,000 musicians
who perform and approximately
1,600 orchestras throughout
the country.
So one of the things
there that I know
from supporting my own
local orchestra in McClain,
Virginia where I live,
just over the river,
is that protecting
our charitable status,
tax-giving status, helps many
orchestras in our country.
Because most of them
are organized
as 501C3 tax exempt
organizations.
And it's also a great way that
any community, wherever you are,
can give back and become
part of something local.
I'm also privileged to
have the Wolf Trap Center
for the Performing
Arts in my district.
And one of the things that
we were able to do when I was
in the state house
was to utilize
that arts center
for STEAM education.
So it's not just about STEM and
the science, but also understand
that arts works together, and
be able to have model programs
that now they are modeling
throughout the program
and I believe throughout
the world.
So young people here, we want
to catch them even
younger in the arts.
So we do know we are going
to have some challenges
on that front coming
up, I imagine.
But I've always been
supportive of that.
And last Congress, we
supported equitable access
to the arts education
in the education bill
that we reauthorized, where the
bill sets aside approximately 30
million to high-risk schools
so they can develop
an arts program.
Those have been somewhat
in decline and we wanted
to make sure that we
could reinvigorate that.
Now we also -- when you
have these local orchestras
and local arts groups,
local music group,
you end up really
providing so much support
for your youth orchestra
too, and mentoring.
And they see people
who are engaged --
I know in our local
orchestra we have a conductor
who not only is the conductor
for the McClain orchestra,
she travels all around
the country
and even all around the world.
So she brings back all of her
experiences and then works
with her local artists who range
from professional musicians
who are part of this to doctors
and lawyers and moms at home
who are sort of getting back
into the field in that way.
And I am always amazed when
I go to our local concerts
to see the variety of people
who are in that program,
and then the quality
of our youth orchestras
because they are part of this,
and that's a big part
of their program.
And they understand the
community support that's going
to be there for them.
So I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here.
It's really something I
think that is a lifelong part
of the learning process and
that the passion that is brought
to all of you who are supporters
of the arts, and transmitted
through all of our
communities and transmitted back
to our children is a very
important part of the heritage
that we can pass on as
part of our country.
That's our privilege to be part
of the Kennedy Center and many
of my local arts groups in
order to continue that effort.
So thank you for being here
today, and enjoy your day
and thank you for your support
and patronage of the arts.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Bilfield:
Hello, everyone,
Jenny Bilfield back again
to introduce our
wonderful second panel.
Hope that you enjoyed your break
and had a chance to look at some
of the archives that library has
so generously set
out for us to enjoy.
It's my great pleasure
to introduce Karen Dillon
who will then introduce her
panel for risk and innovation.
Karen Dillon is a former editor
of the Harvard Business Review
and has long chronicled
the successes and failures
of businesses and their leaders.
She's currently a
contributing editor
to the Harvard Business
Review focusing on topics
of leadership, managing people,
managing yourself
and entrepreneurship.
She's a coauthor
of the bestselling How Will
You Measure Your Life?,
Competing Against Luck:
The Story of Innovation
and Customer Choice.
And she was previously
the deputy editor of Inc.
Magazine and served as
editor and publisher
of the critically-acclaimed
American lawyer magazine,
the London-based Legal Business.
She is currently a global
ambassador for Legal 500,
providing in-depth analysis
of the global legal market.
She's a graduate of Cornell
and Northwestern University's
Medill School of Journalism.
And she was named
by Ashoka as one
of the world's most influential
and inspiring women in 2011.
Please join me as she
makes a presentation
and then invites
her panel to join.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Dillon: Thank you
very much for the introduction.
Good morning.
Very happy to be here around
all these creative people.
It's very exciting to me,
especially talking
about innovation.
Innovation, I come
with a business hat on,
but I know it is
a global problem.
It's a problem for
organizations of all sizes
and types literally
around the world.
And it's something
that in the pages
of Harvard Business Review we've
been writing about for decades
without showing much
signs of progress.
It turns out we may be
innovative people and we think
of ourselves that way,
but by and large companies
stink at innovation.
Let me show you why.
This is data from Neilson which
scans all consumer goods sold,
things you might buy at
Target or the grocery store.
And over a four-year period,
there were 20,000 new
products launched --
these are in the
past four years --
all of which had smart people.
They were good ideas, they
were things that seemed
like they had all the
data and information
to be sure these would be hits.
Only 92 of them were
any definition of a hit.
Most of the other
ones disappeared.
That's a terrible
investment rate
for a company that's invested
time, money and energy in,
trying to create
something, a new innovation
that would bring
them more customers
or make their customers
more loyal to them.
The global consulting firm
McKenzie recently surveyed
global leaders, and 84%
of global leaders said
that innovation was
extremely important
to the success of their company.
If you look at the Fortune 500
from say 20 years ago and now,
that will become very obvious.
Many companies that were Fortune
500 staples then are gone
from the Fortune 500 now.
It's critical to
growth and staying alive
and staying competitive.
But of those 84% who said
it was extremely important,
94% of them were very unhappy
with their company's
performance in innovation.
For some reason,
really smart people
with good ideas keep
getting innovation wrong.
What is it that we're not asking
or doing or knowing that means
that we haven't gotten better?
Organizations have not
gotten better at innovating
over the past decades, even
with all the data we have now.
The technology we can employ,
the way we can analyze things,
we're still not improving
our strike rate.
Well, I will submit to you
that maybe we're asking
for the wrong things.
How do you know what is going
to make an innovation
successful in advance?
Mostly, that 92 hits
out of 20,000 will tell
you it's a little bit
of a crap shoot, hit or miss.
Try a lot of things.
You hope you get it right.
You think you understand
your customers
or prospective customers
and you're going to
create something.
But is that really a
strategy: try, hit and miss?
Is that good enough?
Especially when you have limited
resources as I'm guessing some
of your companies
and organizations do.
Well, I'm going to
tell you a story
about successful innovation
that has nothing to do
with technology, has nothing
to do with focus groups.
It has everything to do
with understanding the
right questions to ask.
This is a story where the hero
of our tale is a humble
dining room table.
So there was a Detroit-area
construction and housing company
that built two-bedroom condos
on the outskirts of Detroit.
And they were really lovely.
They priced them
competitively compared
to other condo types and things.
They create all kinds
of features
that they knew people
would like:
granite countertops,
chrome appliances.
They aimed at downsizers,
people who were probably looking
to move from their house into
a nicer, more upscale community
that would make them
feel special
about the condo they were buying
and the life they were living.
They had many, many people
come and look at those condos.
And yet very few of them
converted to a sale.
They didn't understand it.
They convened focus groups and
they asked prospective buyers,
"What could we add to make
this a more attractive condo
for you to buy?"
And those focus group
prospective buyers had no
shortage of ideas.
Bay windows, squeakless floors.
"I want more options
and cabinets
and the pulls on the cabinets."
They had a lot of ideas.
So they created the
showrooms to do that and show
that they could create
all of those options.
Everything the focus
group participants wanted,
they created a show house,
show condo to demonstrate
that that was all possible.
That didn't work either.
Sales did not improve.
And they were literally giving
prospective buyers everything
they said they wanted.
Then they brought
in a consultant,
a guy called Bob Mesta who was
asked to try to figure out,
how can we improve sales?
They blamed everything:
bad weather,
salespeople weren't good enough.
Maybe the hours were bad.
They tried to fix
all of those things.
And so Bob decided to
take a different approach.
Instead of asking prospective
buyers what would make them buy,
he asked people who had
already bought a condo,
"Tell me about the journey
to make the decision
to buy this condo."
They thought from that
they might be able
to piece together the ideal
demographic or psychographic
of a prospective buyer.
Did they all come from
certain zip codes?
Were they all certain income?
Could you tell by the
car the actual age?
As they went through
interview after interview,
they couldn't see a pattern.
It was really random.
They could not predict based
on any data about that person
if they were going
to be a buyer or not.
But this one very strange
clue kept coming up.
People oddly kept mentioning
their dining room table.
"As soon as they
figured out what to do
with the dining room
table, I was free to move."
That was sort of an odd thing,
because in most cases they
were dining room tables
from the 1970's,
well worn, dinged up,
chunky old style
furniture, not something
that would even make sense
to bring into these lovely,
sleek, two-bedroom condos.
It was only as Bob
Mesta was sitting
at his own dining room
table over Christmas
that he had a revelation.
What does a dining
room table stand for?
Think about your own.
Family. Sitting at
a dining room table,
you've probably had
family celebrations,
birthdays, Christmas, Hanukah.
In my house we did homework
on it, we made forts under it.
The dining room table was a
visual reminder of the life
that these people had built.
Getting rid of it,
just throwing it out
or giving it to charity
felt hard.
It was giving away something
that meant so much to them.
It was really a powerful
indicator
of the significance of the move.
With that insight, we
call that the aha insight,
they realized something
else was going on.
They weren't in the business
of helping people just move
to a new condo or buy a condo.
They were in the business of
helping people move their lives.
So when you think about
innovating, what did they need
to do to those condos to
help people move their lives,
not just buy a new
place to live?
That changes the way you think
about what you need to add
or subtract to make
it more appealing.
They might have cared
about chrome appliances,
but that wasn't going
to trigger them to move.
But when they figured
out, "Okay,
we need to take something away,
20% of the second bedroom,
to make room for the dining
room table," that allowed people
to not have to make that
decision about whether
or not they were actually
going to leave behind
that memory of family.
They could choose to take
it if they wanted to.
They actually raised the
prices of the condos,
made the second bedroom smaller
and then they added
a few small things
in that made a powerful
difference to people.
They created on-side storage
so that people didn't have
to get rid of everything
at one fell swoop
when they were ready to move.
They created a sorting
room on sight as well
so they didn't have to go
through every piece of artwork
from their children's childhood
or calendars and cards,
things they had saved.
You could take two
years to do that.
They increased the price a
little bit, added those services
in and they were able to improve
their sales by 25% at a time
when the Detroit area market
was having a very hard
time otherwise.
They were growing when
everybody else was shrinking.
The aha is in what they
realized: people wanted
to move lives, not
just buy a condo.
Now what is the significance
of this?
This illustrates
something I've been working
on with Harvard Business School
professor Clayton Christianson.
He's been working
on it for 20 years.
Clayton Christianson has been
called multiple times the most
influential management
thinker in the world.
And he's been struggling
for 20 years with the idea
of why are companies so
hit or miss at innovation?
Why are they so bad at it?
And that moving company
illustrates his answer
to the question.
People don't just buy
products or services.
They hire them, in his
language, to do a job for them.
And what we mean by that is what
we call the causal mechanism
in academia.
What causes what to happen is
not anything about the specifics
of the product; it's about
how it helps them do that job
that they're hiring it to do.
Now this may just sound like
a simple language change,
but we think it's a really
profound and significant change
in the way you think
about innovation
so that people will actually
hire your product or service,
in your case your organization.
We mean something very specific.
We call it the job to be done.
People are looking to bring a
product or service in their life
to help them make
progress on something
that they're struggling with.
It's usually surrounded
with complex social
and emotional components
as well, and it's always
in particular circumstances.
You can innovate successfully
if you understand the job
to be done for people
who are your customers
or prospective customers and
offer a solution that does
that job better than
anything else does.
Now let me illustrate so
that you know this isn't just
different language
talking about it.
Thinking about innovation
through the lens of jobs
to be done changes everything.
Table equals family.
You can see the powerful social
and emotional pieces
of that ugly table.
That's fine, it is
an ugly table.
But that had nothing to do
with the function or meaning
of a table to dine on.
It had to do with the emotional
and social pieces of that.
Help me make progress -- that is
what people are looking to do.
And if your product or
service helps them do that,
then you will successfully
bring people to your product
or service and keep them there.
So what changes if you put on
the lenses of jobs to be done?
Look at the problem through
that distinct point of view.
Everything changes.
This is a Sony Playstation.
Who's the competition
for Sony Playstation?
Xbox, maybe Wii in the old days.
Makes sense, right?
And I know that they're
often compared side
by side in sales and prices.
That's how you look at it
and decide which one to buy.
What if I told you this
was the competition?
How about this?
This is my solution.
[ Laughter ]
These are these adult coloring
books, a new innovation.
Have you seen those?
These are all competing
for a different job
than you might have imagined
when I showed the
Sony Playstation.
They're competing for
the job of help me relax.
Maybe when I get home from
work or on the weekends,
help me do something that
will take my mind off
of whatever else is
stressing me at the moment.
Now okay, competing with those,
that sounds like a theoretical
thing, but is that really true?
That's exactly what
Netflix understands.
Reed Hastings who's the founder
of Netflix was asked how he
saw the competition with Amazon
and their videos recently.
And he said, "We compete with
everything you do to relax.
A bottle of wine may be
our toughest competitor."
If you realize you're not
just competing with things
that are exactly like you,
you completely broaden your
opportunities to innovate
and bring more people to you.
You are a solution
to a job to be done.
If it's only something that's
exactly like you that you think
of as your competition,
you probably haven't fully
understood the reason people are
choosing to hire your service
over any other possible
solution.
The job to be done is complex
and the solution is complex
and does not line up along
specific category lines.
And if you can just
begin to think
about what you're competing
with and open your mind to that,
you'll be able to offer a
better solution than some
of those competitions that you
may not realize you're competing
with in the first place.
What does better mean?
I said you'll be able to
offer a better solution?
This is a little hard to see,
but there's an air mattress
up against the wall
in an empty room.
This is not better than a hotel
room by most standards, right?
You probably know
where this is going.
This is Air BnB.
Air BnB was founded not to
compete with hotel rooms,
which is what you might think.
It was competing with not
making that trip at all,
or staying with friends.
And the people who hired Air
BnB in the beginning wanted
to be part of something
and feel local.
They wanted to be able to attend
a conference or they wanted
to feel like they lived in the
city of Paris for a few days.
It was competing with
something entirely different.
It was competing with nothing.
Competing against nothing
is a really good place to be
when all other solutions
for that job are not
better or nonexistent.
The field is wide open for you.
You probably know, Air BnB
is now valued at $30 billion.
It's worth more than the top
several hotel chains combined.
And maybe now they're competing
with some higher-end offerings,
but the innovation came
from recognizing a
different job to be done.
You would never have thought
that possible ten years ago.
So okay, you might buy it.
I like the idea of
job to be done.
Well, how do I find
a job to be done?
How do I locate it in my
community or the people
that we want to deal with?
What you're looking for is what
people are struggling with.
You're looking for
struggles to make progress.
It's always about
making progress
in particular circumstances.
And there are clues that people
give off without even realizing.
Good innovations are
ones that solve problems
that have bad solutions now or
don't have a solution at all.
If your solution to a job to
be done is slightly better,
even a little bit more
than slightly better
than other solutions to the
problem, you're not likely
to win people over to you.
Slightly better does not
cause people to switch.
We know from Nobel
Prize-winner Daniel Kahneman
that people's risk aversion
of loss is so powerful
that they're far more likely
to accept the devil they know
than to risk losing
that for something else
that may be slightly better.
You have to be wildly better
or again, find an opportunity
to compete with nothing.
That's where you'll find
innovation opportunities.
You're looking for workarounds,
things people are doing to try
to make an existing
solution work for them;
that may give you a clue
that there's an opportunity
to develop something
better here.
This is a quick example
everyone's probably familiar
with, Quicken's personal
financial software
which has been around
for a couple decades.
That was on the market for
four years before the founders
realized that something
funny was going on.
They got feedback every year
for those first four year
that people were kind of
creating weird ways to use it
for small business software,
to use Quicken for that.
Funny ways, but they were
buying it for that and using it
for their small business.
And they ignored
it for four years
because they thought there is
really good accounting software
out there that they can buy
that makes your books pristine
and it's like having a
small accountant on staff.
Then they kind of realized that
wasn't what people wanted to do.
They wanted to not have to worry
about doing their books at all.
They wanted it to be simple.
They weren't competing
with that small business
accounting software.
They were competing with
hiring your brother-in-law
to do your books or stuffing
all your receipts in a shoebox
and kind of getting around to
it at the end of the month.
They quickly realized
that and corrected it.
QuickBooks was launched
at twice the price
of the best small
business accounting process
and it was the market leader
within months and it still is.
That whole company Intuit
focuses on the job to be done
with all of their
product innovations now.
Non-consumption.
Basically you're
looking for something
where people would
rather do nothing than try
to solve their problems
because they don't like any
of the solutions out there.
Have any of you seen
those commercials on TV
for Southern New
Hampshire University?
There's a blue bus that's going
around the country handing
out diplomas to people.
If you haven't heard of Southern
New Hampshire University,
SNHU I think they
call themselves
in the commercials, you should.
It's one of the biggest
success stories
in education in the past decade.
Southern New Hampshire
University was the small,
nondescript liberal arts
college it is in New Hampshire
that realized they
were in trouble
like so many other small,
nondescript liberal arts
colleges not competing
at the top level
about ten years ago.
They knew every year exactly how
many students they would get,
how many they'd compete
with from these three
other local universities.
The win and loss rate was
almost always the same.
There was no prospect of growth.
And financial survival
was in question.
Then they kind of realized they
did have this sleepy beginning
arm that was doing what
they call distance learning
for people who didn't want
to come to campus but wanted
to make progress
towards a degree.
Their big aha insight was
that that distance learning
wasn't competing with Harvard
or Yale or even the local
universities around them.
It was competing with nothing.
Those people who were doing
distance learning were trying
to decide if it was worth going
back to school to get a degree
when they perhaps had avoided it
or never had it in
the first place.
Maybe I should just stick in
this job for two more years
and try to get promotions.
They would rather do nothing
than accept a really difficult
solution that would require them
to drive to campus or
take weekends and nights
that they didn't have to work
on extra credit projects
and things like that.
With that insight, you're
competing with "It's better
to do nothing than to pursue
your education further,"
they made sure that everything
about their online
program worked for people
who were working long days,
weekends, maybe sitting
down at the computer
at 11:00 at night.
They didn't need to be as
good as Harvard in many ways.
They needed to be good for the
job people were hiring them
to do, which was
make my life better.
They've been wildly successful.
They stage on campus I think
five separate graduation
ceremonies now.
Not on campus, the town's
biggest place, Verizon Arena.
Because so many people
who have never set foot
on campus all their
years towards a degree,
come for that moment of
getting the cap and gown
and getting their degree.
And it's a huge success story.
They were competing with people
who were choosing to do nothing.
Oops. My clicker's
not advancing.
There we go.
Look for unusual uses.
Any of you ever knocked back a
couple of spoonfuls of Nyquil
when you really just
wanted a good night's sleep?
Lots of people do that.
It turns out the company
finally recognized it.
They didn't need Nyquil, all
the ingredients in Nyquil.
They needed sleep.
Thus, the birth of
Zquil which has none
of those cold medicine
things in it.
That was a clue.
There was an innovation
opportunity to be had here.
Jobs in our own lives.
Most of us actually
know, if you think
about things you're
struggling with,
things that you wish
there were solutions for.
You may be the best beginning
germ of an idea for a job
to be done that you
can share with others.
If you have it, others
might too.
This is an illustration
of Care.com
which is the online babysitter
matchmaking service for parents,
and elder care and dog
care now as it turns out.
That was founded by a
woman called Sheila Marcela
who was having trouble
finding a solution
for her own day care needs.
And she created what is now I
think a $65 million company.
Negative jobs, things we
do not want to have to do.
People don't want to do
this, so any solution
that makes it easier for
them to not fully do that.
Think of the last
time you woke up
and your kid says they
have a sore throat.
You know it's probably
strep throat, but man,
going to the doctor,
what a pain.
You have to call, wait
till the office opens.
You can't go in to
work for a few hours.
You sit there and you know
they're just going to say,
"Antibiotics," or whatever.
Well, CVS Minute Clinic
was born when a dad sat
in the emergency room
with his daughter
for just a little too long and
got a little too annoyed having
to wait for what ended up
being a simple prescription
of antibiotics.
That was what we
call negative job.
I don't want to have to do that.
There's a solution
that is way better
than having to do it, found.
This is really important
to know.
Jobs are not just tasks.
They're not just
something functional.
They involve experiences
and that's really important
to understand, the experience.
This is where the social
and emotional components
of it come in.
You can't successfully innovate
if you just served
the functional need
of whatever it is, because the
other things are actually far
more powerful.
We believe that if you
actually understand the job
to be done properly, customers
will pay a premium price
for a solution that does it
better than anything else.
So this is not a race to the
bottom; this is actually a race
to give people what they most
value and most care about.
Here's my favorite
case in point.
American Girl Doll,
the company's been
around for 30 years.
Many, many people have
tried to compete with it
by creating similar dolls.
You'll see them in
Target, you'll see them
in the Disney Store, Wal-Mart.
Have any of you ever paid the
current price, I think is $120,
for an American Girl Doll?
Me. I've bought several of them.
And then the wardrobe
on top of that
which you could buy
an outfit for yourself
for some of what you pay.
Do you think we're paying $120
for a doll because the dolls are
so special, the individual doll?
They're nice dolls, but I
don't think there's anything
incredibly special
or unique about them.
We're paying for something else.
What's the real job of
the American Girl Doll?
It's a chance to connect
with our pre-teen daughters
and nieces and children in a way
that we didn't think
we could before.
People said there
was no doll market.
Girls aged out of dolls
at age seven before American
Girl Dolls were invented.
And Pleasant Rowland the
woman who started it was told,
"There's no chance that
this will succeed."
The only options at
that age and stage
up to age seven were Cabbage
Patch dolls in those days
and really hyper-sexualized
Barbies
and Bratz and things like that.
And that wasn't a good
enough answer for her wanting
to connect with her nieces.
American Girl Dolls not only
come in a very special box,
the experience of going
with your mom or your dad
to get your doll --
this is a sample.
I actually took this
off someone's blog
where they were doing highlights
of their cross-country
trip with their family.
This is one of their highlights.
This is the American
Girl Doll restaurant
where if you don't have a doll,
you can babysit one
while you're there.
They have birthday
parties there.
There's something about
having that special experience
with your mom and your dad
that people remember forever.
And the dolls all
have backstories,
historical backstories.
There's something that makes
us feel good as parents
about giving our children
American Girl Dolls
because they're substantial
and maybe we'll have
conversations
about the feelings.
$120. I can't think of any
product that you willingly put
up that kind of money for.
But this one absolutely
understands the job to be done
and everything about the
American Girl Experience is
tailored to that.
Again, you put on the lenses
of seeing a job to be done
and not just the function
of a product or service.
Everything about
what goes into that
and how you treat your
customers, how you talk
to your customers, changes.
So I'm going to ask you --
I heard a lot of interesting
things this morning
at the panel discussion
about what job --
you didn't use those words,
but that's what it was --
what job orchestras
have to do now,
or people want to
hire them to do.
It's changed, clearly,
from the old days
where perhaps it was clearer.
Are you selling a product?
Or are you solving
a job for people?
One of them will give you
ample opportunity to innovate
and potentially charge
premium prices
and competitive advantage,
all things all organizations
want to have.
Because people will know
that you've helped them make the
progress that you want to make.
The other one is just as good;
the next competitor will
be compared side by side.
You've reached success when
people don't shop around.
They just know that they want
to go straight to your service.
They want to go straight
to what you offer,
because it does the job
better than anybody else.
That's what we call
a purpose brand.
You want to be a purpose brand
for what job you're
solving best.
And I'm going to illustrate
this, the difference
between talking about the
product you're selling
and selling your
response to a job.
If you could show
the first video --
this is an old Snicker's
commercial.
>> Can I help you
enjoy that Snicker's?
>> [Singing] Happy peanuts soar
over chocolate covered
mountaintops
and waterfalls of caramel.
Prancing nougat in the
meadow sings a song
of satisfaction to the world.
>> The world!
>> That's right.
>> Karen Dillon: Okay, we
heard about prancing nougat
and waterfalls of caramel.
Those are all the
features and benefits
and the quality ingredients
that go into Snicker's.
Is that exciting
as a commercial?
Do you think that makes
anybody want to go?
Put on your own lenses
for your own organization?
Are you doing a version of this?
Talking about the
ingredients and the quality
and all the components
that you know are superior,
but maybe just add up to a
list of things to offer people.
Now from a different
perspective, if you put on a job
to be done lens and you think
about, how are you talking
to your customer, how are
they seeing you as a solution
to their job to be done,
you'll approach it
entirely differently.
Snicker's now is one
of the bestselling --
I think it is the bestselling
candy bar in the United States.
And one critical insight I
think led to that development:
they recognized when and how
and why -- the job to be done --
people actually hired
a Snicker's bar.
It turns out a lot of us hire
it when we're hungry and angry,
a concept they call
hangry, right?
It's not necessarily competing
with Three Musketeers
or any of the others.
It's competing with
peanuts or food or a meal.
You're hungry and you
want to be fed quickly
and you want something that's
going to stop that hangry thing
from taking over really quickly.
If you watch in airports, you'll
see lots of people buy Snicker's
and they think it's
people who are racing
for planes and haven't had food.
It's a very different job to be
done than just something sweet
to fill me with joy
at the moment.
So this is the approach
they've taken.
It's a very clear job
to be done communication
about hiring a Snicker's
bar when you're hangry.
If you could play the next one.
>> Hut!
[ Grunting ]
>> Come on.
>> Mike, what is your deal, man?
>> Oh come on, many, you've
been riding me all day.
>> Mike, you're playing
like Betty White out there.
>> That's not what
your girlfriends says.
>> Betty.
>> Oh.
>> Eat a Snicker's.
Better?
>> Better.
>> Hut.
>> I'm open.
[ Grunting ]
>> That hurt.
>> You're not you
when you're hungry.
Snicker's satisfies.
[ Laughter ]
>> Karen Dillon:
See the difference?
The fact that we all respond
to that second commercial means
that we understand that concept
and we might hire a
Snicker's when we're hangry.
How are you talking
to your customers?
And your prospective
customers, and the customers
that are hiring nothing rather
than solving their
job to be done?
Do you know what the
job to be done is
that you've been hired to do?
If you don't, I would urge you
to think long and
hard about that.
Talk to the people who
already have hired you and talk
to people who haven't hired you
at all to try to identify that.
Because once you
have that in mind,
it can become a real
guiding beacon for all
of your innovation
efforts and one
that we believe is far
more likely to succeed
and not leave you vulnerable to
the hit or miss of innovation.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
>> Jesse Rosen: Karen, thank you
for that fantastic presentation.
>> Karen Dillon: You're welcome.
>> Jesse Rosen: Entertaining,
and you kind of drove us right
to the intersection
of art and business.
>> Karen Dillon:
>> Jesse Rosen: And we're
going to get right to that
in a second, but let me
introduce our panel first.
And I'm Jesse Rosen,
president of the League
of American Orchestras.
Kevin Shuck runs the
Boulder Philharmonic.
He is a molecular
biologist by training
and avid outdoorsperson.
We'll hear more about that soon.
Sandi runs the North Carolina
Symphony, also has worked
with the Seattle Symphony,
Cleveland Orchestra,
great colleague.
And Sarah Kirkland Snider, a
composer whose biography reads
like a Lifetime Achievement
Award.
She has been performed by every
major orchestra, collaborated
with every major
artist, commissioned
by every commissioning source
and an extraordinary talent.
Thank you and welcome, panel.
>> Thank you.
>> Jesse Rosen: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Gosh, there's so many
places to jump into this.
The Snicker's commercial,
the first one
with the guy singing
actually reminds me
of orchestra press releases and
brochures from not too long ago.
Where they just heaped
praise and praise
and praise upon themselves
in describing all the ways they
were wonderful in the same way
that guy was singing
about the Snicker's bar.
And now of course orchestras
communicate about themselves
and express themselves
very differently.
And maybe it's a place
to jump in to pick
up with Karen's last
question, which is, you know,
how has our job changed?
And there was certainly a
time I think when we thought
about orchestras were doing
products and services.
We created concerts
and people came.
Now we kind of think we
maybe have a different job.
And Sandi, why don't you start
us off, maybe with a reflection
on where we've been and
where we're going to?
>> Sandy MacDonald: Actually I'd
like to reflect on
the presentation.
What business am I in?
Or what's the job
I'm trying to sell?
So I believe that in the case
of the North Carolina Symphony,
we are not seeking to
be the Chicago Symphony
or the Cleveland Orchestra
or the Berlin Philharmonic.
We are seeking to be the
orchestra of our community.
In our case, we serve the
entire state of North Carolina
through orchestral
performance as well
as our music education series.
And so we want to provide music
that is unique to our area,
to our orchestra, because you
can get the greatest Beethoven
symphony performed by the
Berlin Philharmonic --
they do that really well.
But what we do very, very
well is produce concerts
that are meaningful to a North
Carolinian, and you will hear
that tomorrow night
at our performances
at the Kennedy Center.
So my job is to find
those tentacles,
to find those opportunities
to connect with our community
in unique and different ways.
>> Jesse Rosen: And is
that a relatively new
development in orchestras?
We've been in the field a while.
Has it kind of been
that way for a bit?
>> Sandy MacDonald: I
came to North Carolina
from the Cleveland Orchestra.
I don't know that we spent a lot
of time talking about connecting
to the musical DNA
of our community.
>> Jesse Rosen: Right.
And Kevin, how about you?
How do you think about the
job of orchestras today?
>> Kevin Shuck: Sure.
I think there's a lot of
resonance in how we think
about it at the Boulder
Philharmonic
with what Sandi just
said in North Carolina.
It's that well, in our case,
about eight years ago --
so you're asking how
recently these kinds
of thoughts have been
in the orchestra field.
About eight years ago our board
had done a strategic planning
exercise, whereas our
goal as an orchestra was
to reflect those qualities
that make our community
unique and special.
Every community is
unique in different ways.
And so I think in our case we
were just looking to tie music
into in our case what
makes Boulder unique.
And you know, I think that's
very much part of the Zeitgeist.
It's what at League of American
Orchestras conference we're
talking about a lot these days.
And it's good to see
orchestras like this week
that are having some
success in those areas.
>> Sandy MacDonald:
We also codified --
our board codified our
point of view on programing
to be uniquely North
Carolina-focused
and of national significance.
But we've been doing this
work in the early 2000's.
>> Jesse Rosen: And Sarah,
a different kind of person
than Sandy and Kevin
and Karen and myself.
You're a creator.
And so how do you
think about this?
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider:
How do I feel about --
>> Jesse Rosen: How do you think
about the job you
do as a composer?
And has that changed for you?
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Yeah.
Well, as a composer, I
think what drew me to music
from the very beginning
was the power of music
to communicate and
express emotion.
And as a child, I was just
utterly fascinated by that.
And still to this day
I feel that my job is
to communicate something with
an audience to put something,
a feeling that you
can't put into words.
That's what music
can accomplish.
So yeah, I really see my job
as being one of communication,
and that's not necessarily
true for every composer,
but for me it definitely
feels that way.
>> Jesse Rosen: Great.
And I'm kind of curious,
thinking about some
of these changes that
are taking place.
The question Karen poses
in her presentation
about how do you know,
and how do you come
to understand your
constituents, your public?
And in the arts, this
is kind of a little bit
of a different question
than it is in business,
because after all, we're
not exactly prepared to give
up everything we do in order
to become something else
because it's more profitable.
That's not our thing.
So Kevin, talk a little
bit about this question
of how do we balance
what we come
to know an audience is looking
for with what we feel is
somehow defining of who we are.
What can change?
What can't change?
>> Kevin Shuck: Sure.
Well, the first thing about
the job that is to be done,
I think with orchestra concerts,
I think it's a challenge
because there are
different segments coming
with different jobs to be
done in a single concert.
So that makes it difficult to
balance all of these things
and to come up with a
satisfying experience.
But it is also I think
a great potential
for a very rich experience.
And what I mean by that is
there are people that are coming
for the sole purpose
that they want
to hear the great live jukebox
for this music they know,
they've learned and they love.
And I think that's the
traditional job that we think
of orchestras as doing.
Well, you can still do that and
at the same time be thinking
about what are the social
reasons that people are there.
And I think there's
a lot of resonance
to what Sarah was saying
about the emotional
resonance of music.
I think orchestras are uniquely
positioned to create community.
In our current world where it
is highway, suburbia, fast food,
these things, people are looking
for a place where you can come
and there is an authentic
connection.
Orchestras are uniquely
positioned to do this
because we are bringing together
people in a shared space
for a shared experience.
It's something very
different from the day-to-day,
and I think that that is
something that we can harness
as organizations to really
create something very special.
And so as far as the job to be
done, I think that you know,
certainly there's
this relaxation
or leisure time bubble.
And so we think, who are
we competing against?
We're competing against Netflix,
we're competing against
the couch.
So really when you look
at this leisure bubble,
you're really talking about
there's a subset of that
which is in some way
people are looking
for something that's more
fulfilling or enriching
or special or has a night
out component to it.
And so I always think that our
biggest struggle is growing the
piece of that leisure
time relaxation pie
that people are looking for
those kind of quality outlets.
And so I think that leads a
lot of the thinking that we do
about how are we going to
get people into concerts.
>> Jesse Rosen: So I
know a lot of people
who would violently disagree
with the idea that going
to an orchestra concert's
a great way
to be together with
other people.
I mean after all,
it's a terrible time.
It's 8:00 at night.
You have to rush through
dinner, you get home late,
you have to listen to music,
some of it you might like
and some of it you
might not like.
And it's really expensive and
you can't talk, you can't drink
and it's formal and
rigid and uncomfortable,
unlike most other
performing arts experiences.
So unless I'm --
>> Sandy MacDonald: Where
do I buy a ticket for this?
[ Laughter ]
>> Jesse Rosen: I think
there might be more than one
or two people who feel that way.
So how does an orchestra
confront some
of these very changing
ways that people feel
about going to concerns?
>> Kevin Shuck: Well, you've
ticked off a lot of barriers
that we are always looking
at and talking about.
I think one way we
think about it is,
how can you put out
the welcome mat.
Because yes, if a newcomer
to the performing arts,
orchestras in particular,
is just looking at it,
all of those negatives are
just too easy to think of.
So instead we try
to think about,
what are the entry points, what
are the doorways we can create,
what are the welcome
mats we can put out?
And so in our case at
the Boulder Philharmonic
in Colorado, I mentioned
that we are trying
to reflect the qualities that
make our community special.
And so a lot of times that means
meeting people where they are.
In Boulder, that usually
means on a trail somewhere.
I think last week it was the
city with the highest rate
of exercising or
something in the country.
It's very overachieving
in many dimensions.
And so in our case, we thought,
okay, well how do we meet people
on their turf so to speak and
create a welcome mat there?
And in our 2013-2014 season
we were exploring works
that were inspired
by the natural world.
When you come to Boulder,
that's one of the first things
that you notice is we have
this very scenic backdrop,
and that's what draws
a lot of people there
and that's what people
are actively enjoying.
So that's part of your
culture and that's
where people are spending
their leisure time
and that's what their
interests are.
How can you then convert that
into a welcome mat to get people
into the concert hall?
So since we had a list or
repertoire of composers
that were inspired by music,
we were commissioning new
works along this vein as well,
we had the crazy idea to reach
out to our city open
space department
which is a big deal in town.
And I wrote them a
letter basically saying,
"We're performing music
inspired by nature.
I think we should collaborate."
And I went ahead and mentioned
a few possibilities for this,
thinking that they'd either
just laugh me aside --
but within two days
I was meeting
with the entire senior staff
of the open space department.
Because they said,
"That's exactly what we're
interested in."
So we've been using our
collaboration with them
to create that welcome mat,
to kind of put all
those negatives aside
and actually show that it can
be something that is social.
People on the trail are enjoying
conversations, sharing music.
And when they come
to the concert hall,
it's the same as well.
During intermission,
people are buzzing.
I met people that I met
on a hike that we do.
Then I'll see them at the
concert hall and it's like,
"Oh that's just amazing.
When I heard that piece, I
could just see the geese flying
over the Sawhill
Pond," for example.
>> Sandy MacDonald: Kevin
mentioned collaboration
and I think that is an area
where we invest a good amount
of our time to create
programs where we collaborate
with another organization.
One example is the Museum of
Natural Sciences in Raleigh.
The museum created visuals that
celebrated the 100th anniversary
of the state parks
of North Carolina.
We performed the four seasons.
And together, this performance
which couldn't resonate
in any other state
than North Carolina,
our audience members --
which expanded to the museum's
audience members as well
and those people just
interested in the state parks --
brought together the sum of all
those parts, something bigger
than any one of us could have
been, and create a performance
that can't be replicated
by something else.
Listening on the radio -- how
old of me to mention a radio.
[ Laughter ]
Or you know, watching
Netflix or doing nothing.
You had to be there
in that space
to see those three critical
elements brought together
in performance.
>> Jesse Rosen: I love it.
And Sarah, you've
created a piece
that the North Carolina Symphony
is going to play in a couple
of nights, on Wednesday night.
And I understand that that
came together in a way
that also really
brought people together.
Could you talk a little
bit more about that?
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Sure.
Yes, so a few years ago Martin
Share came to me and said,
"I understand that you have
some family connections
to North Carolina.
Would you be interesting for
writing a piece about that?"
And I jumped at the opportunity
because North Carolina
has always felt
like my spiritual home,
my ancestral home.
My family had been
there for 13 generations
and my father was the first to
leave and he worked in New York,
so we lived in New Jersey.
But we would spend a lot
of time during the year
in North Carolina and
I really thought of it
as this place where I belonged.
So I was very excited to write
this piece, and I thought,
what should it be about?
I thought it should be
about those feelings
of what does home mean?
And what is a longing for home?
What does that feel like?
What is that about?
You know, is it about family?
Is it about landscape?
Is it about the things
that you did there?
So I decided that I would try to
write a piece about the nature
of memory and longing
for a place in your past.
And I had this idea that
it might be interesting
to combine it with a film
component, because so much
of my memory of North Carolina
was sense memory based.
You know, the way things looked,
the way the sunlight
cast shadows
on my grandparents' patio,
the way that the town looked.
The things that I
did with my family --
I thought it would be
interesting to look at some
of that from an abstract,
cinematic perspective
and to have that
accompany the music
so that it would be this kind
of dreamy exploration somewhere
between memory and a dream.
But one that the audience
would have some kind
of reference point for
the emotionally journey
that the music was exploring.
So we went down to
North Carolina
and shot some footage actually
of my own children
recreating some of my memories
and my father's memories.
Yeah, so it became
a real sort of look
at small-town life
in North Carolina.
>> Jesse Rosen: And it's been
performed already, right?
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Yeah,
they performed it several times
last year in North Carolina.
And also in New Jersey.
>> Sandy MacDonald:
Your hometown, yes.
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Yeah,
the other co-commissioners,
the Princeton Symphony
which was the actual place
of my birth and growing up.
So that was neat as well.
But yeah, they performed it too.
>> Jesse Rosen: Yeah.
And how did the origin
of the work --
I mean, when it was finally
performed, what kind of impact?
What was the significance
of all that led
up to creating the piece when
it finally came to the public?
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Well
that was what was so remarkable,
was having all of these
friends and family
from North Carolina
come to the premier.
And they felt so
emotionally connected
to the piece and what they saw.
And for them it really resonated
with their own memories
of North Carolina.
So that was really
extraordinary, just the senses
of community that was
brought about by the project.
A number of the people had
participated in the making
of the film, had recreated a lot
of these social scenes
that we shot.
So it really felt like this
galvanizing collective memory
exercise in a sense.
And that was really
special, yeah.
>> Sandy MacDonald: And
we were able to perform it
in the community that evoked
all of these memories.
So it was very North Carolina.
And we've had two performances
of it there and performed it
in other locations including
our headquarter hall in Raleigh.
>> Jesse Rosen: Right.
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider:
And that's what's amazing,
is actually a lot of people from
North Carolina are traveling
up for this performance.
>> Sandy MacDonald: Yeah.
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider:
They feel a sense of ownership
and investment in it,
which is really special.
>> Sandy MacDonald:
Sarah is a star.
[Laughs] I just hear a
job in that right away:
make me feel proud of
being a North Carolinian.
And you've checked
all those boxes.
It's maybe about the music,
but the music is a way
to achieve the progress, right?
Make me feel proud of it.
I hear success and a job there.
>> Sarah Kirkland
Snider: Thanks.
>> Jesse Rosen: So I'm
thinking back to Karen's slide,
the one that showed
92 out of how many?
>> Karen Dillon: 92 out
of 20,000 products, yeah.
>> Jesse Rosen: So listening
to you, it sounds like we're
in the 92 camp, that somehow
we've figured this out.
>> Karen Dillon: Right.
>> Jesse Rosen: I mean, people
have written so many books
about innovation, it must
be hard and complicated.
So I'm curious, as you
go through these changes,
is there any tension
around this?
Or is it just you've
got it all figured out?
>> Kevin Shuck: I think
there's inevitably tension
when you go outside of the
box of a traditional art form.
I think that's just kind
of taken for granted.
But, well, two things about the
words both innovation and risk.
I really don't like to
think that we're trying
to innovate all the time.
That's actually not kind
of the vocabulary we use.
We're instead trying
to be creative.
And I think that it's about
looking for the connections,
looking for ways that music
can reach different parts
of your community.
In doing that, the
end result is often
that your programming
is innovative.
But we're not pursuing that
in and of itself as our goal,
because I think that leads
you down the rabbit hole
where you could be doing
things that are different just
for the sake of being different.
Rather than if you are
following from the standpoint
of where the art takes you,
where that creativity takes you,
then it leads you into
a more authentic place
that might happen
to be innovative.
And I think that as far
as, is there a tension --
I mean, there are certainly
traditional audience members
who are happy with the
music just the way it is.
In talking to a lot of
people I hear this, "Well,
I understand why you're
doing that," because they see
that our audiences are
growing by leaps and bounds.
So they see the effect of it,
they are invested in the music,
they want it to be successful.
So they get behind it.
Even though that's not the
job I guess they're looking
for the concert to
fulfill for them,
we're able to bring them along,
because they see the effect.
They see that it is
done in a way again
which is authentic
and not gimmicky.
Which again, I think if
you focus on just trying
to be innovative, that's where
you can end up a lot of time.
And so that's how we've
been able to manage that.
>> Sandy MacDonald: I
would just argue though,
that might be doing
the job for them.
The job for them might
be, "I want to be a pillar
of this community and
this is the way I feel."
If you think narrowly
about what the job is,
again you think innovation is
a rabbit hole, it might be.
But if you think about the job
and you only add or focus on how
to make that experience
better, they still feel
like a pillar of the community.
Maybe you've done it better
because you're a
growing organization.
It's not an either/or.
>> Jesse Rosen: So if
the job of orchestras,
or among the jobs are creating
experiences that connect
with people, connect
with community
and move beyond the
transactional product,
we're selling the concert --
so is this good for business?
>> Sandy MacDonald: Certainly.
>> Jesse Rosen: Because you're
running businesses too, right?
>> Sandy MacDonald: Yeah, yeah.
We're running business
and we worry a lot --
I spend a lot of time
worrying about risk
and limiting the risk,
the financial risk.
And so we've come up
with some solutions
that reduce the risk for us.
So for example, everyone
wants the millennial audience
and the illusive
millennial audience.
And so there was a time
we would put on a concert
that had hybrid music in it
and our marketing department
would be in the corner stewing
about selling tickets and where
are they going to come out,
and let's get food trucks
and let's sell martinis.
Moving away from actually
what our business is.
And a couple of years ago we
decided, let's take that money,
let's eliminate the tension
within the organization.
Let's talk to our
musicians about a concept
of giving them money to develop
a program that would be held
in for example a club in
our case in downtown Raleigh
that I would not go to.
Well, maybe Sarah
would go to it,
but most of us might not go this
because we wouldn't even
know about the club.
The marketing would
not darken my door.
And you know, can we
be more successful
at reaching an audience
that we're not reaching
in a traditional performance?
Close up and personal
with our musicians
who have chosen the repertoire
they're going to play,
who have used their
social network
to bring people to the concert?
And let's not charge
a ticket price.
Let's have a cover charge.
And so those reduce
the financial risk.
Let's not put these in big giant
halls, because they don't belong
in big giant concert halls,
and stew about filling
all of those seats.
And let's make the
connection that way.
And so that's an example of
it making sense both in terms
of resource and inspiration, I
posit to our musicians as well.
>> Jesse Rosen: And are
you seeing positive changes
in attendance at the
North Carolina Symphony?
>> Sandy MacDonald:
Over time, we have, yes.
Yes. We've grown our
ticket revenue by $1 million
in this planning cycle
that we're in right now.
We're at the end of a
five-year planning cycle.
And that's by doing a
variety of different things,
not just performing Beethoven
symphonies, but making sur
that we're reaching out
to the entire community.
Yeah.
>> Jesse Rosen: Kevin,
how about you?
Good for business?
>> Kevin Shuck: Yes,
it's good for business.
Since 2009 our ticket sales have
grown 66%, subscriptions 44%,
contributive revenue
by similar amounts.
And I think it's because when
you do this type of work,
you're increasing the
number of stakeholders
in your organization
and the community.
So if you do one of
the collaborations
like what Sandi was
talking about,
which is a really key
part in these years,
45 different organizations
we've collaborated with.
And some of these are
what you'd expect,
other performing
arts organizations,
but some are what
you would not expect,
like social service
organizations.
Or nature and science
and youth organizations.
And every time you do it, you're
going to get new ticket buyers
in the door, maybe just
for that one concert.
A certain portion will come
back, but even for the people
that didn't come to the concert,
they now have a touchpoint
for your organization.
So they think that, oh, this
organization supported something
that I care about,
so it's a checkmark
in your column for good favor.
And I think that
community goodwill can't
be underestimated.
The snowball effect I
think is really what it is,
is that each time you
do something like this,
it's another ripple in the pond.
You're reaching additional
people.
And sometimes we go
to a lot of effort
for something we think is a good
idea, that really makes sense,
and maybe the impact is not
as big as what we'd hoped for.
And sometimes it goes beyond
our wildest projections.
But it's a cumulative effect.
And it's I think committing
to this type of approach,
systematically and organically
throughout your organization
which over the long
run has these benefits.
>> Jesse Rosen: Right.
Sarah, I'm not going to
ask you about business,
but I am interested -- as a
creative person working a lot
with orchestras, what's
the optimum for you
in a relationship with an
orchestra that allows you
to fully realize all of
your artistic aspirations?
>> Sarah Kirkland
Snider: You know,
I've had a really
extraordinary experience
with North Carolina
working on this project,
because we've had
multiple performances,
multiple rehearsals.
Getting that kind of time to
get to now a conductor and get
to know the members of the
orchestra, the administration,
really enables the project
to go that much deeper and be
that much more satisfying.
I've since revised
the piece a few times,
and I'll be revising it again.
So yeah, I think that having
any kind of second performances,
multiple performances
for a composer these
days are pretty unusual
in the orchestral world.
So having a chance to go deeper
is really pretty extraordinary.
But I think any time that an
orchestra can take a moment
to really work with a living
composer is an incredible
experience for everybody.
I mean, it's great
for the community,
it's great for composers
obviously.
It's great for the orchestra
to feel connected to living,
breathing music that
they can have a role
in introducing to the world.
I just think the more
that living composers can
be introduced to orchestras,
the better for everybody.
>> Jesse Rosen: Yeah, kind of
the center of the whole thing.
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider: Right.
>> Jesse Rosen: So Karen, you've
had about three hours to get
to know the wonderful world
of orchestras [laughs].
From what you've
heard, challenge us.
You're an expert on this stuff,
on shifting and changing.
What words of wisdom?
>> Karen Dillon: One word of
wisdom I would sort of pass
on from Clayton Christianson
-- they're not original to me.
But the reason that so many
great organizations ultimately
fail when faced with competition
from what he calls disruptors --
small upstarts that initially
you don't see as a threat
and then little by little
they gain market share.
Great example is Blockbuster,
now bankrupt, and Netflix.
Netflix was a disruptor.
His theory is called the
theory of disruption,
more famous than the
theory of jobs to be done.
It's that the incumbent,
the established company,
in the face of that
competition they get nervous
and start making their
product better and better,
more expensive, add
more layers of gold.
You know, they make
it so that they want
to make it more valuable
to their customer base.
But what that does is it makes
them have an increasingly
smaller customer base
because people start deciding,
"This is good enough.
Why should I spend that?"
So I would just hear --
I love hearing some of
these creative ideas
for alternative things here, the
caution to not chase your market
up further and further to
the point of losing them
to a disruptor because you
think the best response
to that threat is
to make ours better.
Again, I would say
better in what way?
Better for whom?
Better for what job?
Make sure that better
is always focused
on what those customers want.
And it's okay if it
comes in the form
of disrupting yourself
with smaller ideas.
I mean, you might as
well disrupt yourself
and get all the revenue
from both the disruption
and the existing one.
So just to be careful not to
over-gild the lily in search
of better when better is when
people come and hear you,
however you want to be heard.
Just keep that in mind.
>> Jesse Rosen: Terrific.
Well, before a hangry assaults
all of us, let me give each
of our panelists a minute
to talk about your concert.
Kevin, yours tonight; Sandi,
Wednesday night; and Sarah,
you can tag-team
your Wednesday night.
Tell folks about your concerts.
>> Kevin Shuck: Okay.
Well, the Boulder
Philharmonic is honored
to kick off the inaugural
Shift Festival tonight.
Our program is, as I mentioned,
has an unabashedly programmatic
title, The Nature of Music.
Which is bringing all those kind
of initiatives I was
just talking about to DC.
We open with a new commission.
It was commissioned
with National Endowment
for the Arts money, the
Imagine Your Parks Initiative,
to commemorate the centennial
of the National Parks Service.
We have an adventurer-composer
who we've worked
with before, Steven Lias.
It will be the premier
of his work inspired
by Rocky Mountain National Park.
After that we have a mandolinist
from here close in Virginia.
His concerto is called
From the Blue Ridge.
So our goal with the
Nature of Music was not just
to show off Colorado with
lots of pretty pictures
of our mountains, but also that
these things are universal.
So we have something from
local audiences here as well,
from your backyard as well.
The second half opens
up with a piece,
Ghost of the Grasslands,
by Steve Heitzig.
This is about the prairies, the
lesser-known half of Colorado.
And interesting, percussionist
drummers like Stalks
of Prairie Grass, Bison
Bones, Squeak Toys that Sound
like Prairie Dogs, and then that
takes us into the grand finale
which is Copelands Appalachian
Spring with something
which is pretty eye-popping.
Frequent Flyers Aerial Dance
Company we brought with us
from Boulder do a
beautiful rendition suspended
above the orchestra.
>> Sandy MacDonald: Wow.
And I have my tickets.
[ Laughter ]
So the North Carolina
Symphony is bringing a program
that demonstrates who we are.
We have two works by Robert
Ward who spent the mature part
of his life in North
Carolina and was the dean
of the University of North
Carolina School for the Arts
and eventually became
an audience member
of the North Carolina Symphony.
So we bookend the performance
with two of his works.
We will be joined by North
Carolina-born Pulitzer
Prize-winning composer and
performer Caroline Shaw
who will be the soloist
in her work, Low.
And let me think -- thank you.
Mason Bates -- I was going
to hand it over to you.
Mason Bates work is evocative of
his time spent in the Carolinas.
I believe he uses
cicada in his sounds,
in his piece called
Rusty Carolina.
And then the big centerpiece of
our program is our co-commission
of Sarah's work, which maybe
you could tell us a little
bit about.
>> Sarah Kirkland
Snider: Oh, okay.
I felt like I gave you a lot
of information, but the name
of the piece is Hierite.
That's Welsh word that means a
longing for a time or a place
in your past that you
can no longer return to.
So yeah, I'm excited about that.
>> Sandy MacDonald: And then
on Thursday night we'll be
at the Cogod Gallery or
the auditorium, thank you.
Space. Courtyard, there you go.
Space. And with a program that
we performed at an art museum
on Saturday night that featured
Sarah's piece Unremembered
that has been traveling
the globe.
And so her piece
with our orchestra,
and as well a piece called
By and By, by Caroline Shaw.
That program is an example
of the North Carolina
Symphony getting
out of a traditional concert
hall which we do frequently
and performing our works
in a different space.
>> Sarah Kirkland Snider:
I think it's worth highlighting
too that something special
about North Carolina Symphony
is that they like to go deep
with the composers
they work with.
So they do multiple pieces by a
certain set of composers rather
than lots of pieces by
lots of different composers
which I think is really special.
Because it enables the community
to get to know artists better
and feel a stronger connection
to each piece that they hear,
because they have a
little more context for it.
>> Jesse Rosen: Right.
You know, earlier today
some of us right here
in this library were looking
at the original manuscripts
of Mozart and a lock
of Beethoven's hair
and Bartok's manuscript
from the concerto orchestra
Heiden Symphonies.
And I couldn't help thinking
about this great sense
of tradition and old stuff.
And here we are hundreds
of years later,
we're still playing
the same music.
We're still playing
the same instruments
and the same orchestra.
And it reminded me -- this
will sound a little crazy --
but I've been watching the
hearings for Judge Gorsuch
and so the word originalist
which I didn't know before --
now I know what an
originalist is.
But the tension around
you know, the past
and how does the past live
as you go into the future,
is a question that kind of runs
through so many aspects
of our lives.
And I think the work
happening in orchestras
of asking those same questions,
we know this incredible
tradition.
We learn from it, we revere
it, we're in awe of it.
And yet we're also
in a completely different
place and a different time.
And so how do we make that
alive and real for today?
And I think that's kind of the
journey orchestras have been on,
along with probably
the rest of America.
So anyhow, thank you
for being with us,
and a big thanks to our panel.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Bilfield: Many thanks
to our panelists
and participants.
Thank you for being here.
And just a final word, if
we have piqued your appetite
and you don't yet have
tickets for everything,
they're still available.
I hope that you'll find
the Shift events located
on the Kennedy Center
website, also at the bottom
of the Washington
Performing Arts homepage.
Just click a link and it will
take you to a whole series
of residency events that
are free in the community,
as well as the performances
that start
up in the Kennedy Center
tonight on Main Stage,
Millennium Stage,
all over the city.
Please join us.
We need your energy, we want
your support and participation.
Thank you for being
with us today.
Thank you to the Library
of Congress for hosting.
We look forward to
seeing you this week.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]